we are here to present the award for
I'm a vampire salarians Robbie's racism
Abraham owner are here today to present
the Oscar for Best live action short the
nominees see are the nominees this year
shows that when it comes to making an
impact on a big screen size really
doesn't matter here allah nominees for
Best live action short film Ave Maria
Bassel Khalil and Erica - Part B 1 Henry
Hughes everything will be ok
Allison veered good Patrick full rat
shock genie gonna go straight over
Benjamin Clary and Serena Armitage and
Oscar goes to star
this is the first Oscar and nomination
for Benjamin Cleary
you know when you make your your
first-ever film you gotta convince a lot
of people to jump on board and take a
risk with a first-time director and you
know - every single member of the cast
and crew of stutterer for attempting on
board and taking that risk with me I'm
forever grateful and to the Academy for
this award it's such a huge honor thank
you so much to my amazing parents for
all the support thank you
Chloe Perry you're amazing where we were
up there and Matthew to the wonderful
Matthew Needham you are this film
brother thank you so much every day is a
prayer date to be iris but today more so
than usual Tavor over all the support
back home thank you so much and behalf
of myself and Sean who produces film
with me we just want to thank Ben for
bringing us on a journey and the Academy
for honoring short films thank you Joe